so
have some things I want to give away in context of who we
are the stuff that we bring as
an organizational to start this PowerPoint because
it's going to act as our guide tonight.
Yeah.
So first stone Ministries is give a
little bit of an overview of our organization. We've
been around actually in Oklahoma City
for a long time and our
history started in founding as
a corporation in Oklahoma City as
Fishers of Men In 1976 changed in
1983. When a network of Ministries
at that time got its Charter which was called
Exodus International. We were one of the founding ministries of
that as well. Unfortunately some of
the history of that I'm not going to go into all that but it it went
into hyper Grace and antonym and basically gay
Christianity and imploded from
from the top but many
of the ministry. This is what
you will not hear in the gay meeting or
media is that we're still here.
And we're still doing the work.
We get our name from The Gospel of John
chapter 8, which says let him chapter 8
verse 7, which says let him who's without
sin cast the first stone and
a lot of times we love to unpack John 8
because John a actually answers a
lot of questions that a lot of people convey concerning
that Jesus never said
anything about homosexuality and the bottom line on
that is he never had to and that's a whole
nother teaching but wanted you to be aware of a
little bit more of our history. We've been now a full-time Ministry for
31 years. And as a
part of The Exodus implosion, I
was the chairman of the ministry Council that behind the scenes
brought the charge of Correction and the antinomianism
the hyper Grace the gay Christianity
and so as a
part of that and as a part of other leaders, we had
to form a new network of Ministries.
That was biblically Orthodox and we did
so in 2012 and so there's
a whole nother network of Ministries that help
people overcome all forms
of homosexuality lgbtq, and
that plus sign and folks.
If you don't know what that plus sign is, you may
need some education on that. You'll see a little bit of the plus
sign tonight very quickly, but we are squarely the
biggest thing. I think that we like to say about
ourselves is that we're a Ministry of the Gospel
of Jesus and that doesn't mean just a tagline,
you know, gospel Ministry. We
really want to provide the words
of Jesus Christ to the soul that
brings about what Paul told Timothy
a Pure Life a life
of Purity and surrender. And so
that that's who we are. We have a staff of six
of us one's not
here tonight, and you're going to get to hear from these amazing people
in their stories tonight.
To really proclaim the glory of God and what
we do in discipleship care, we offer
one-on-one. We Minister and groups. We
do public teaching and really try to
equip the body of Christ. You'll see out there
is a literature table that's got
lots of some of the most pertinent questions that
we get out there. So all the literature out
there is freeing for the taking now, there
are three. There are a few items out
there. I have three here that are
not for the taking but I want to give three way
we have some fun with that and Jim's birthday
stand up Jim Farrington. So
his birthday is July 5th.
Who has a July 5th birthday in the
room?
Being you in it. Okay, Jim if you would give that
to that lady in looks a tan
coat. Okay, and then Pastor Scott,
that's where where is he?
He was here right? Anyhow, he?
I'm Phil I said Scott Phil his birthday.
There. He is. His birthday is 12:21, right?
Who has a birthday near 1221?
Anyone a week at this Christmas? Okay. Well, what's
your birthday?
Okay, that's probably it is the 19th
the closest. All right. This is the
In His Image DVD pack. It also
has an extra bonus that has 25 other
videos that answer pertinent questions
about this. If you would give that to that man, and then
you're going to hear from one of
our staff members who lived a transgendered lifestyle
Laura Beth Perry Laura Beth if you would stand up
and this is her book and she was
born on September 3rd and
you get to give it to him.
Oh, I'm sorry. That's right. She injured her foot.
so, this is Laura Lee giving
they're out there September 3rd. Yay. Awesome.
So we we like you to
have and a big part of our ministry is getting
educational materials. And this
is just a little bit of what we have here tonight. We
have a whole library of stuff and lots
of Articles. Now one of the things that's very different
about my book is we
conducted a survey no other Ministry and
all the history of quote unquote ex-game
Ministries. I don't like that term but it's a you
know media sound bite. Yes. I'm ex gay, but
No, Ministry had done a survey on 25
years of client folders because a lot
of the Ministries weren't that old and thank God we had
a social worker who had the wherewithal to
say. We need to track people.
So we had intact folders for 25
years of people and we contacted them
and as a result of there is a fact sheet
out there and the survey and
and it's also in my book and the
last two points and it's in the slide presentation,
but I'll go ahead and mention it now.
92 to 88% of the
people that had come to first stone Ministries considered
themselves completely sexually
broken or addicted with little
progress.
After they received Ministry services from first
stone, most of them several years. I would
say 72 to 73 percent in
this survey show that they
considered themselves free from sexual sin and
Brokenness and living free from any of
those lgbtq+ labels and then
awesome and glory to God, right?
Because honestly when we did the survey I was
thinking man, I'll be glad if I know you know,
Alan Chambers told the world on Oprah's network that
99.9% of people don't change and you'd
be surprised how many people even in the
church repeat that well nobody changes.
You can't change orientation is fixed. That's a
lie.
And we'll get into that more later.
There is a handout out on the table
out there only brought a hundred.
This is a great crowd.
And if you want this you can get this digitally and this
will have all of what I'm talking about plus a
whole lot more and all the scriptures.
So we want you to be equipped and then this AFA Journal
goes along with that DVD that
has mine and Laura best written testimonies. So
this is a big part of what we do we
want to educate is as many
people that are here. We have a fantastic website
with lots of quick links and
easy ways to get information. I have
a Blog
the the book itself has its own
website with all this information.
The fact sheet is on the website as well.
And so we came here to talk about an overview
of homosexuality. You're not going
to get everything. There's a lot of times we will go into churches
and we will break out a lot of
what I'm going to like give you the shotgun approach tonight, but mainly
to underscore the testimonies of
the Lord that make wise as simple because in this
day we need to be making wise people
are simple-minded in believing
The Narrative of the culture that believes
that God isn't working and changing people's lives. So
we need to testimony that people can
really be set free. And so we're going to bring that is
anyone born homosexual and causealities. We're
going to bring that and we try to really as
an organization to underscore everything we
talk about with scripture.
To back it up with verses.
Now there are some things in life in getting
God's will like, you know, should I buy that
house? You might not have a Bible verse on that one.
But there are some things that are just really clear.
Really black and white and human sexuality is
actually one of them.
And then so we do use some psychological perspective
and I would say it's more about
the relational Dynamic like one of
the things I love to use is his needs her needs
by doctors.
I want to say Smalley, but I'm
Hardly, yeah, and you know, you you
look at some of the the differences in
men and women and you know, you realize okay that may
not be right out of the Bible, but it's very helpful and things
like that that we have found. So you'll see that and underscoring
this.
That the Bible is true.
And I was praying about coming tonight and thinking
about this and a lot of times people
will say well I need to know how to help somebody. I
need to know how to help a family member. I need
to know how to help a coworker. I I don't I
don't have the verses right? I don't have understanding but
actually you'd be surprised what
you really do have.
relationally and revealing the God
of Wonders in nature and
it comes right out of Romans chapter 1 which a
lot of times the
Gay Christian activists will say well. Those are the clobber verses.
Well, actually no, they're the delightful verses of
the word of God that bring transformation and changed my
life.
completely
over 40 years ago. I celebrated on February 6th
my 40th spiritual birthday this
year and it was an and I
mean an artist surrender to Jesus for
40 years.
And I'll share more about that. But this this thing about
nature.
And the glory of God revealed in nature.
He shows you he shows all of us.
That he is present. So his even his
eternal powerhead and godhead.
So that everyone is without excuse.
If you really want and seek God
he will give you the truth and you'll hear in my testimony and
every one of their testimonies God gave
us his truth and it
transformed Our Lives my life first and
Laura Beth Perry's life verse same verse for even new
one. Another Psalms 107 verse 20,
he says and he sent his word to
heal them and to deliver them from their
destruction and he did
that in my story and you will see it but for tonight,
I want to show you a two minute little
clip of nature, you know,
Oprah has her things that she likes right.
Things that Oprah loves things that Oprah like so this
is one of the things I love I love this DVD called
the God of Wonders and this is
the introduction to it. Just watch the
glory of God in this little video clip.
you are
it
he is the God of Wonders.
Every single thing that you just saw
is a witness of the glory
of God.
and every single thing that you
saw is teeming with life
with DNA
that was just discovered in the last. Thank
you, brother. Just
Since 2001 was the entire human
genome.
mapped
since 2001 we're only we're only you know, 20 something years
into understanding even greater levels
and depths of DNA.
Why is that important?
Because on the scientific side of this.
We win.
We win completely and the brilliance.
And the Majesty of the mind of
God.
Is ever in every single one of you to testify
of the glory of God and you
don't have to start with homosexuality with your
gay identified loved ones.
They need to see the glory of God revealed in
your own life, by the way that you live.
and every every strand of
every single created thing you saw
screams
there is a Creator and a designer.
And that sins like riveting chill bumps
throughout my body. I've seen that documentary. I've memorized
many of the facts from this documentary. It's on
YouTube now, it's free.
And the doctors and the scientists and
the the phds that specifically look
at their areas of expertise of
every single area of nature.
And design of everything you saw and so much
more.
That they are able to conclusively point
to there is a Creator a designer
and he has made us clearly male
and female X Y
male XX female and yes, there
are abnormalities and we will look
at that later in the evening, but I'm telling you it's screams
that God has created us in
His image and the image of God. He created
them male and female and there are answers to
transgenderism and queer. Now if
you're hearing you hear that and that seems shocking that's
not a derogatory term anymore.
That's it. And when I was growing up,
you know in the 70s.
That was a derogatory term.
Now it's an identity.
It's an identity of a person who wants to Proclaim. They
have no gender. They're non-binary
or as someone who
is they're queering it trying to figure it out by practicing
all kinds of sexual behavior.
This is the culture we live in now.
So it's really important to know there's so much
more we could talk about concerning the science, but
I just want to I didn't
put it in the PowerPoint, but I do want to just
read this out loud. I love God's word. It really
has just totally changed my
life.
And many people when they see this they'll see
this in context, you know about Psalms 19. I
want to read this. It's just so magnificent starting
in verse 7.
the law
of the Lord is perfect converting the soul.
Hmm really? Is it confer? Does it
really Challenge and transform exposes? It
does it did me and this
is part of my testimony.
The testimony of the Lord is sure making wise
the stem the simple the statues of
the Lord are right rejoicing the heart.
The Commandment of the Lord is pure
enlightening the eyes the fear of
the Lord is clean enduring forever.
The judgments of the Lord are true and
righteous altogether more are to
be desired then gold yea then fine
gold and sweeter also than the honeycomb and
more over by them is your servant warned
and in keeping them is great
reward. That's that's part of
my testimonial verse and then the grace of God has
appeared unto all men bringing salvation
Titus to 11 and 12. We
have Grace that is said, oh it's just unmerited favor.
You can do whatever you want. No Paul's letter
here in Titus Chapter
2 verses 11 through
14.
Says it instructs us to deny
ungodliness and to live righteously
right now in this present life.
And that's what we teach and disciple and
Pastor Souls into to receive the
grace of God not in vain but to receive
it to rest the power of the Holy Spirit to bring
about transformation and that was certainly true
of my story. So in a group like this,
I would imagine and some of
you may be shocked but the latest stats from
the pier.
Once they Barna it's not Borno the other the other
group that does statistical.
the latest numbers
for Evangelical churches
Bible believing churches Catholics and
even liberal Christian churches.
The number is around 15
to 17 percent that believe
in heaven and hell and that the Bible is true
and that
that gay living a gay lifestyle is
sinful.
And several years ago of another statistical
thing that was run by Christian Broadcasting Network
along with focus on the family. It showed
and this was Man 10, 15 years ago. It showed
that 60% of the
youth groups.
across all Evangelical youth youth believed
did not know the first and first and last
book of the Bible didn't know the name of it.
They didn't know the names of the four Gospels.
They didn't believe that Jesus lived to send us
life.
They didn't believe that that Mary was
a virgin.
But guess what they did believe.
About 15 years ago. You think it might have increased a little
bit in 15 years, you know what they believed in.
UFOs
and that gay marriage should be allowed.
So I think scripture is really important.
And so we and we usually will take
at least an hour. You're so glad I'm not going to take all this time, but knowing
the word of God about sexuality and
homosexuality is probably very
imperative for the Christian church today. Especially Christian
leaders. I was in a conversation
with a dear friend, who is the national
radio host.
Just before getting here tonight.
And she was telling me about a conversation with another National
Pastor that if I drop names you'd
probably know them. I won't do that.
but the conversation is going like this
and that is
Steven remember when you talked to us and was talking
to some leaders about homosexuality and Holiness
and I said, yeah. Yeah, and she goes well we're having
this conversation again, and now at the
top places in
The Southern Baptist Church and I go to a Southern Baptist
Church that my interests and she said to
me that yeah, you know, you've heard
the messaging before now. Can I just ask
and she's wanting to pick my brain how to communicate this
and bottom line was
If you are male and female.
If you are x y and x x you are
innately biologically created
in the
image of God heterosexual.
Heterosexuality is not an orientation.
Heterosexuality is a part
of how you've been created as a human being.
Now unfortunately, you know psychology came in
the 1870s and gave us these words. You
know what it was called back in then before we had all
these orientations.
male
and female
right
So when we described human beings they were male
and female. I mean some of this some of you may go.
But we are so distorted we have this thing so
jaded and when you even hearing
me say this some of this may seem well, that's silly. Well
who you've been listening to?
You've been listening to the culture that tells you that orientation or
your great PhD leader in
the church that tells you that it's it's viable that
yes, there is gay Christianity and we should embrace it.
I could name all kinds of names that have done this. So scripture is
really important. We start off with Genesis. These are
the verses everything that are on the handouts out
there. We start off with the idea. We're made
in God's image. And then I think it's important to understand
the the story about Sodom and Gomorrah, but before
that the rainbow,
Do you know when I see the rainbow Banner which is
not really called the rainbow Banner anymore. It's called The Pride Banner.
I weep.
I weep because I see the prophecy of what's coming.
in second Peter chapter 3 isn't it interesting that
the very
Icon of judgment seem a
lot of people when they see the rainbow. They they think of only about
the promise that God is not going
to destroy the entire Earth again
by flood by water.
But they missed the other part of the promise.
God is going to destroy the Earth again.
by fire
and I just think it's I ironic that the
very people group that this flag
because I'm a vexologist means study of flags and I
have flags and all my office and I love the history about
flags and I and I thought how ironic that
this flag is flying over a people
group.
That are lgbtq promoting
the idea of sodomy.
so
very important to know the scriptures on this we're going
to fly through this very quickly because you want to hear some amazing
testimonies.
We could go through all these verses a lot of times people good bible-believing
Christians say, well, there's only like
two or three verses in the Old Testament and maybe
two or three verses in.
The New Testament I'm going no. No, actually there
are 10 passages of scripture that
in one way or another deal directly with
homosexuality in the Old Testament.
Leviticus 18:22 and the
reason why this is so important in the law of the Lord converting the
soul and I'm gonna get ahead of myself because I'm just going to go roll through
my testimony real fast.
The night I was saved.
I was led to the Lord by some
people in a little trailer park in the coma Park.
And I heard this voice.
And this voice in my mind said if you do not accept me tonight,
you're going to die.
And I I pretty much thought it was God. I
mean because the only voices I ever
heard was something you know perverted and it was like this has to be
God and then my heart was racing racing and
all I know is I needed to ask this
guy named Steve.
I need to know God Like You
people because there was something amazing in their
home.
The presence of God was in their home.
And so we prayed the prayer and then on my way
home. This girl asked me this question.
Does this mean you're not going to be gay anymore?
And I said
I don't know.
I guess it means whatever God has for me.
So I went downstairs took this big
do-way version of the Bible Blessed Pope because
we were raised Catholic and there's so much
there could talk to you about but big big book this
book Family Bible the just
off at lugged it down prayed over it and said
the priest in my mom's Parish in Midwest
City was telling me it's okay to be gay wink wink
all the reason more to come to mass even
trying to seduce me. I'm like, I'm really confused.
So I opened up the Bible and lo
and behold. I mean he's got all these pictures from the
bat again and all kinds of stuff. I flipped
that thing open.
Guess what passage it landed on?
This life giving passage
that most people hate to even
quote in context of homosexuality Leviticus
18:22.
You should not lie with the malice woman with a woman. That's an
Abomination. And when I saw that verse I was like,
oh my gosh, they've all been lying to me.
Because you know, I thought it was born gay.
Because you know back in the late seventies and
even in the early eighties, you know, you're born this way.
And the law of God hit me that night in a
way and I thought it's really in the Bible.
And I believed.
And I got down on my knees. I said God, I don't even know how
to change.
And I got involved with some people that were on fire.
for the Lord
and there's a monument to it's a little teepee church
out of 178th and MacArthur.
And God transformed My Life by that
pastor's love.
Set Me Free with the word of God but then there's a Dr.
Robert Gagnon one of my mentors in
the Lord one amazing man of God told me
about there's a run on you know, that's a run-on
sentence.
the very few pastors will ever touch
and that's verse 23.
Well, we better start touching it because you know, what's
happening in the culture.
It's changing really fast.
They're changing the glory of God to Incorruptible God
into the image of corruptible, man.
Even President Biden's nuclear waste
manager with his red mohawk.
engaging in what's called Puppy Love
And now this is mainstream. I know some of this may be absolutely shocking
to you. But this is Frontline stuff. I'm dealing
with every day now.
front line
and guess where if it's coming to us and the
future persecution coming to little Church Ministries, like
first stone. Guess who's next?
So this is really important to know that they are coming for
our children. And if I we had time we could
even watch them singing about it. So there's lots of
verses in every single verse in the Bible new testament
old testament always always condemns
homosexual Behavior to
say otherwise is just just disingenuous or
a woman should not wear anything pertaining
to a man now, isn't it interesting
since 2015 what has
happened just since 2015 anybody like
football in here.
Anybody like ESPN?
They gave Bruce Jenner the courage award.
for transforming himself
That's sweet.
It's where our culture is, right? So then it gives way
to this.
Two years later. We have this new thing called drag queen Story Hour.
And this is happening all over the
country. And yes here in Oklahoma City.
And I can tell you lots of stories about this but these are
all the different places that's happening in libraries and
in schools across our nation. It is to normalize
lgbtq to children and
ironically some of
the biggest leaders in the Nea want this.
Now this is the you see
the pink.
That is a quote from drag queens themselves.
Drag queens are lgbtq adult entertainers for
lgbtq bar audiences
and many are strippers.
And many as strippers they provide the most bile displays
of sodomy and gay bar atmospheres for fun.
adult entertainers for toddlers
An elementary school, I mean, you know when I
was at Catholic School parochial school we talked
about maybe bringing a clown in.
They said no clowns are much too scary for
children to bring in. You know, we can't bring in clowns.
That looks pretty scary to me.
Anyhow, just wanted to drop that that this is really something because
they're saying that the reason why God
destroyed Sodom and Gomorrah was because of their in hospitality
and unkindness and yet
the New Testament actually tells us the
truth. Also in Jude's passage that actually
was destroyed because of their sexual impurity. Look
there's ten passages of scripture that in one
way or another deal with human sexual Brokenness specifically
speaking to sexual immorality.
There's a lot more than just two verses folks.
And you know every single time it underscores
the practice is immoral. Do you
not know that the unrighteous see
it's asking a question because I think it's pertinent even
to today's Church.
Do you not know?
That those who practice such things that they're not inherit
the kingdom of God.
Did you did you know that your Bible actually says that oh, but
wait wait, I'm a good Southern Baptist.
I'm go to Southern Baptist Church. God say I
pray to prayer.
Oh, no, no, what about believing resulting in
righteousness, you know, there's not more parts
to the Bible in Romans 10.
Yes call upon the name of the Lord but be transformed and
then you see there's a whole list of
sins. It's not we're not just singling out the homosexual.
So important to know that this is actually in your
Bibles and I love this and such
were some of you but you were washed.
Such were some of us we were washed. We were
justified in the name of the Lord Jesus Christ and by
this spirit of God, and there's many other verses we could
go into and look at they're all here. We break them out
a lot of times. We'll take another hour. Just talking about this.
But I want to get into the testimonies and I want you to hear our stories
and I want you to understand that up
here you see.
Causalities and if you'll pay
attention to these and you may not be able to get this
right here and take a picture of it or you can get it in
my book or on the handouts.
But perception can be really real in a
young person's life that they somehow feel you know
that they're born in the wrong body.
Or that they're homosexual like I was I you know.
When you see my story you'll see you know, there's formation of
early childhood development. This is
the stuff we unpack that is a bit psychological but
still truth bearing.
It still gives raisins and it gives hope when
you have knowledge knowledge can
equip but knowing him will do better.
knowledge equips but knowing Jesus will say
And then defensive Detachment, you know that Walling off
a deal with so much I had it all of us have had defensive
Detachment in one way or another which is you know,
Walling off your heart from your same sex parent.
And then these other things family history family background
arrested emotional development where you
don't develop don't fail. I mean, honestly, I
wasn't until I was in my late 20s and 30s
and there's a couple people here that used to go to church out there
at the teepee church and when they saw me coming in that church
like and that was Cowboy Church and they're going oh my goodness
what has just walked into the door.
You should have seen me 40 years ago now.
You know, maybe not quite the stud that you
would like for me to be but I've come a long way,
baby.
And peer pressure is a huge
thing. This is one of the most diabolical things
that I think is happening to our children.
Our children. We're talking Elementary School.
So my story real short just gonna put
it out there because I want to my staff to share.
There's causality sexual abuse.
ridicule
beaten
I was what they call, you know, the emotional sensitive artistic
young man.
Dad was out of the pitcher and Julie Greenland or Taiwan
and other places in the military career military
stationed out here at tinker.
And I didn't know Dad for about the first six years of my life when he came
back into the picture. He was scary.
Disciplinarian good old country boy
from Kentucky married my mom at the
end of World War Two and stationed here
in Tinker. She's a war bride from England.
And this this boy was one messed up
young man.
To where by the time I was 14, I was completely engrossed
into a world
of homosexuality and honestly some
of the Rich and Powerful in this city at the
time.
It's heartbreaking.
and the level of delusion I was under
to allow men to do what they did to me thinking it
was love.
But Jesus got a hold of me in 1983 in
my life has never been the same.
And he used his word to heal me but you
know what the testimony goes on right and it should go
on.
one of the most
challenging and Faith testing things I
ever had was the day. I took a national stand against
Exodus International in the antinomianism.
My daughter went into the hospital that night.
She was a daddy's girl. She was so much
like me.
Her name was charity. Hope
The next day she died from an unexplained
brain. Tumor.
Aneurysm wasn't aneurysm is
a mass in her brain. We never
did find out what it was.
But I knew then I was in
one dark spiritual war.
And the testimony of the Lord is is I don't care what you've
gone through.
What pain you have faced?
Jesus is enough if
It's that giant word if if you'll keep
drawing near to Him He will draw near to you.
This was the last family picture. I have I have
a son who's 34 and daughter Mandy
my oldest in the middle got married. This was
her wedding.
And charity on the end and their spouses.
And charity did marry and she had
a little boy and the last thing
she said to me and she was holding the little boy and steady. I really
did want to raise him. So honey, you're gonna
get to race him daddy. This is so serious. So no
you're gonna get to raise him and I just knew I
believed with all my heart that God was not going to allow.
Her to die when I am so totally surrendered to
God with my whole heart.
But he did.
And he's taught me a lot of things and I'll just tell you the Book
of Job has become a big friend to me.
That's why I like showing that nature video because God
addressed Joe. So we'll
let some of these others come and share.
One of the microphones right here.
Okay, it wasn't ready to go first.
well
I want to start off with Mark chapter 10.
verses 17 through 21
A man to purchased Jesus and says to him.
Good teacher what must I do to be saved and Jesus says, why do
you call me? Good? There's no good. But God Alone.
And he says you need to do this this and this and he
said I've done that for my youth.
and
and it then it says in verse 21 and this is
really important because we hear a lot about how Jesus just loves Jesus
just loves he's all love.
And it says Jesus looking on the man loved him.
And said to him one thing you lack.
Go sell all you have to give it to the poor and then
he finished with this take up your cross and
follow me.
It's about a Crucified Life.
In 1999. I came to a place
where I had been I had sacrificed every ounce
of dignity and energy pouring into
a homosexual identity.
Um, and I just came away disillusioned and
disappointed and despondent and really wanting to
be free and from 1996 to 1999.
I just I kept running into this
same thing. I don't want to be gay. I don't want to be gay.
I'm tired of being gay.
But I I wasn't willing to surrender it wasn't
really willing to lay my life down.
And then God's mercy he would bring people into my
life that were the presence of God the kindness
of God.
They weren't trying to change me. They weren't condemning me. They
weren't beating me over the head. They were just loving me. I worked in a restaurant. So
I was bringing them foods that that's probably why they were so nice, right?
but
but I had one one specific night that I had this
I was supposed to wait on this one table.
And I got taken from that and put on this other table and it was
these three ladies. I got over here to these three
ladies and one of them said you're gonna think I'm crazy, but God's
trying to get your attention and he wants to talk to you way. A father wants to talk
to his son.
And at that point I had already been aware that I think God
is pursuing me. I just don't know why.
And you know, I've done all these things and I've rebelled against him. I
don't know why.
And I had her write it down for
me and I have it laminated. I keep it in my Bible.
but she says
the father of all creation wants to talk to you and it's a serious
matter.
And I knew and I told her you're not crazy. I know you're
right.
And that that brought me to a place where I could I could I
could
I was willing to lay my life down. I I said to to the Lord if
it kills me. I'm gonna follow you, but I can't live like this anymore.
And you know for three years trying to get free and
never being able to get free.
And then within 24 hours of that moment.
I knew something had changed.
And my friends would come by the house and go. Hey, we're gonna go party and
like
that's not me anymore.
And I had one one man at work that says so this
mean you like girls now and I'm like, that's not what this is about.
And I say that and the next following four
years. Whereas My Discovery into who God created
me to be and the identity he gave me as a man.
And one of the things that was a huge
Revelation and like Stephen has said I realized I was through
scripture and through through communion with
the Lord that I had been created heterosexual and
I only struggle with homosexual sin and that changed
everything because it meant that I could take that old identity and laid
it down the cross and received from Jesus everything he had
for me.
Now what began to happen is that how did
I end up with this?
Gay identity so I had to look at my history.
And the Lord empowered me.
He had me he gave me the strength to
be able to look back into my past and I uncovered I
had over 34 different people that poured into me sexually from around
the age of six or before to the age of 14.
And I had a broken relationship my father. My father didn't have
anything to do with me because I wasn't manly boy. I was
also like Steven very sensitive and tender
and creative and talented emotional.
And I had a codependent relationship with my mother.
And I got a hold of some
material that was put forth by Dentistry Ministries
and it uncovered this Brokenness toward
my mother.
And it revealed my mom and I are
not close. I was under the impression for years that we were close.
And I realized no we're broken.
you know, but then I was like
But wait, there's more.
So, how do I do it the more?
And and what was interesting is that for those those
last remaining about 10 years? I was living homosexually.
I was getting the first stone newsletter.
And I was reading testimonies of people's lives are
being transformed.
And there was this there was a spot in the back of my mind when I would read these testimonies
and and the newsletter. I would see a cluster
of grapes hanging on a vine the sun's glistening
off of the drops of water falling off of the fruit.
You know, it was like life that we could
see life in it, right? It did wasn't enough for me to go. Okay. I'll
stop being gay now, but it gave
me hope that that there was
that there is an answer there is hope out there, you know.
I just had we threw all of that mess and that's what brought
me back to Oklahoma City to go through Living Waters and
start doing the hard work of uncovering all the
things that happened. I mean, I took on a gay identity at age
12, I didn't even know anything about sexuality, but I just figured
this must be this must be what I am because
this keeps happening to me.
You know my parents weren't there to protect me and nurture me
and guide me and they weren't the scaffold around that I needed.
But but at first stone, I began to get the language that
I needed to know that Jesus had the
ability to come into these broken places and
and bring healing and restoration and
identity.
And and you know, it's interesting
in my mom. My mom was
really funny and coming out of all of that. She had
been exposed to all of my mess and there
was one particular day that we were walking into a Walmart
and she said, you know
You look really comfortable in your sexuality and
she was talking about the Redemptive one.
Right, I'd exposed her to everything, you know, experiment experimenting
with drag and what have you
and and all that confusion and she didn't know what to do with me.
But anyway in my involvement with
first stone, I got the language that I needed to begin
to say yes to Jesus and all the
places where I was broken and
and it it's brought me to this point where now I'm on staff as
immense Minister. I lead our parents support group because I have a
36 year old daughter who identifies as lesbian,
but she's saying she's not mind non-binary and I
have a 39 year old daughter.
And and one of
the things that I love about what we do is that is
that the word of God is true.
That I'm standing here because
the word of God is true. It says that he who
laces life down for my sake this thing will find it and that that's
I found that that's that's exemplifies my
life. I laid it down in Jesus said this is who you
really are.
And so that's why I'm here.
Hey there.
I was born into a family of three older siblings.
My mom a homemaker and my dad a wheat and cattle farmer.
We attended church every time the doors were open.
Before I was school age, my father expressed the word stupid and
discussed over something that failed to
work to his benefit.
Seeing an opportunity Satan caused this word to pierce my
heart.
I then took on an identity that was never meant to
be.
Anytime work with my dad went poorly.
I felt the sting of the words. You're stupid
ringing around in my mind.
I grew angrier.
with my father
in fact
I hated him.
I'm the youngest of four siblings and there's
a big age gap between me and the rest of them.
And my older siblings went to school out of town away.
So I didn't get to know them very well growing up.
The brother I was around most teased me for not
being physically strong enough to do certain tasks.
Well, I hated men who were similar to my dad. I
admired other men exhibiting physical strength.
confidence
and compassion
the admiration digressed into Envy
and eventually lust
I became hooked on pornography and masturbation.
As early as 10 years old.
Throughout my teenage years. I was crying out to God
for help.
Through the words of the Prophet Ezekiel in chapter 36 a
verse was extended to me.
I will give you a new heart and I will put my
a new spirit within you and I'll remove the Heart of
Stone from your flesh and give you a heart of Flesh.
And I'll put my spirit within you and cause you
to walk in my statutes.
And be careful to obey obey my rules.
This Promise came at a good time
I was losing hope that anything could break through my sin
hardened heart.
God began to demonstrate his love for me in overt
ways.
Upon that Foundation. I've been slowly learning how
to apply his word and his ways into my
life.
Some of the biggest growth points have been building
strong against accountability into my technology.
Processing what's actually going on in my secret
thoughts for giving those who have offended me
and learning how to express my anger in
constructive ways.
One such Milestone was that I chose to forgive
my father.
This enabled me to renounce the LIE of believing that
I was stupid.
fast forward 13 years ago at the
age of 40
I decided I needed a complete medical checkup.
At that first meeting my doctor exposed me.
To something that rocked my understanding of
myself.
Our sex chromosomes tell us that XY is
male.
and x-axis female
while my physical body tells me that I am distinctly male.
My sex chromosomes tell me that I am XX y.
And Genetically speaking.
I have an intersex condition.
One out of 600 men.
The stat is even better one out of 450
men in some surveys have this condition.
And for each of us our sperm isn't viable for producing
children.
and our bodies produce little if any testosterone
Which contributes to physical strength stamina confidence
and a positive sense of
well-being?
The self-hatred that I had of my body was deeper
than what I had learned in pornography and in
comparison to other men.
My brother's teasing.
finally made sense
some men who have this condition experience confusion
in their gender.
While there is no doubt that I am a man.
Being genetically different. How am I supposed to view myself?
Listen to God's perspective on this from Isaiah 56
verses 1 through 5. Thus says
the Lord keep Justice and do righteousness
for soon. My salvation will come
am I righteousness will be revealed.
Blessed is the man who does this and the
son of man who holds it fast who keeps the
Sabbath not refining it and keeps his
hand from doing any evil.
Let not the Foreigner who has joined himself to the Lord. Say the
Lord shall surely separate me from his people.
And let not the eunuch say behold.
I am a dry tree.
For thus says the Lord to the Unix. He
keep my sabbaths who choose the things that please me
and hold fast my Covenant. I will give in my house
and within my walls and monument and a
name better than sons and daughters.
I will give them an everlasting name. That shall not
be cut off.
What is true about me is that I am created male by God
In His Image?
I'm also a conduit of God's tender powerful
and affirming Grace. We're both myself and for
others in the body of Christ.
I need God's grace to walk out my male gender.
According to his ways while building up my emotions
and my abilities according to God's will for my life.
I need his grace.
to deny false Idols of masculinity
of confidence and of strength
So in an act of solidarity with God's word, I am
choosing to delight and being fearfully and wonderfully made in
His image.
Well, I still find myself in the strength of
man.
I am not a homosexual.
I am made in God's image and it was created for Pure relationships
with men and with women.
Thank you.
I
the director of women's Ministries
But how do you get into a job like this?
Well, I'm redeemed liar and Deceiver.
sexually seductive
with a history
beginning from very young
kindergarten, Maybe
Have committing predatory behavior in my classmates my
friends my cousins.
and all the while being hungry
for the knowledge of God
being hungry for his ways.
But the disconnect was just ridiculous.
Titus describes me really well.
says they profess to know God but
by their deeds they deny him.
Being detestable and disobedient worthless for
any good.
So what does God do with somebody like this?
Well, he starts drawing.
A lot of the a lot of the people that I encounter people
who are trying to find an answer for their loved ones,
too.
But I'm I was one of those.
I'm the one that says I wanted the church and I
wanted his ways, but the disconnect was just
ridiculous.
But he's faithful and he does draw.
And I think that's kind of shocking.
They can come after the liar
and the deceiver the seductress.
the abuser
and give them life.
Maybe it came out of a an honest set of
needs.
One of my earliest memories is trying to
look up the look up the skirt of my kindergarten teacher
during nap time.
There was something in me.
That was dark.
Something in me that lived guilty.
Something in me that my conscience was.
I was
Honestly, I was continually.
disobeying my conscience
By the time I was 11, I was fully sexually addicted.
My identity was being formed by my
Hunger for pornography.
Pornography was the giving me images
and giving me material to understand
Colonel knowledge in ways that formed me.
Right alongside that thing happening in me.
Some horrible things were happening in my
family as well.
my beautiful intact pretty secure family
came under its own Warfare. My mom was diagnosed with
a progressive form
of multiple sclerosis sclerosis. And we
lived with that from the time. I was seven years old until she
passed away when I was 50.
And fear entered into our household I was
so susceptible to fear.
The what I would do with the anxiety, what
I would do with the pain is I would use.
Those images that forbidden material those
forbidden encounters to calm myself
and soothe myself.
And it went on like that. I began to trace images
out of the pornography that my dad had.
Was tracing paper and I kept it in a
little cigar box had my own private stash.
And I kind of lived off of that material. I knew when
I began to babysit. I knew where to find it in other
people's homes.
I I began to pursue
and look for that everywhere. I went.
When I was 17, my dad was diagnosed.
With an aggressive form of cancer and I
lost him.
And that left me with a mother who was Ill
fatherless?
My little sister two years younger than me, and
I was on right on the cusp of
graduating from call. I mean College High School.
and so all of these pieces that the the things
that I was forming in myself and my hiddenness
and Disobedience and the things that were being formed in me by
my circumstances
were altering my perception of
myself.
I began to I began to have relationships with so
many kinds of people different kinds of things encounters. Let's
just call them all kinds of encounters. But
by the time I was about 13, I I
began to be very exclusive in what I
preferred.
And even though we didn't tend to
label it.
Like kids are offered nowadays.
At that time by my behavior. I would
have said I was becoming
a gay identified person. None of
that language was given to us.
And maybe that was a mercy.
So I lived in this identity this duality
of Christianity.
and gay
not ever calling it that wanting so
much the way of the Lord.
But the duplicity was starting to tear me apart. I
dealt.
From the time I was really young with high levels
of anxiety.
inability to be consistent
I would I would consistently fail at things I attempted to
do because anxiety would just overtake me.
My formation is in my Humanity was
weak.
Now I'm going to just skip us several years because something miraculous
happened.
I was at Oklahoma Baptist University and I I had a
couple of teachers who were mentoring me at the time.
Who who wanted me to
embrace some of these?
issues in my soul
and so my writing teacher was giving me assignments to to
Cull out the material that was going on
inside of me.
And I I was dismayed.
At the identity that was emerging the truth of the thing that
was emerging.
But at the same time there was a little church in South Oklahoma City
who had they had a radical prayer meeting.
And so those crazy people on in
the mornings would get up and they would face the
North
From South Oklahoma City, they would pray for everybody up this
way that they knew who needed salvation and they
would turn around in the church and face the South and pray for the people to
the South. But when they faced East from South
Oklahoma City they were praying for this girl.
in Shawnee, Oklahoma
Who desperately needed the truth?
So imagine they're surprised I had no idea imagine. They're
surprised when a friend whose car
broke down asked me for a ride to this church that
was experiencing some level of a
move of God. They had done crazy things like repent of
being a democracy nuts my friend
wanted to see that she gave me a ride.
And the girl that they had been praying for walks into a South
Oklahoma City Church.
I heard them gasp.
I had no idea what it was about.
But I the one that they had been praying for by name
was suddenly in their midst.
and over the next
I haven't told the story that way no before the
one that was in their midst was suddenly in
a place to receive the Gospel truly
received the gospel.
And I heard I heard this good news.
That the god that God reveals himself.
To people so that the truth of who he
is is revealed.
And he calls us to repent.
Now I have a new definition for repentance. You
know, we always talked about doing the total
turnaround the 180 the about face.
But you know the minute I turned toward
God.
Sin was at my back.
now
I came to Faith I received forgiveness of sin.
But I did not have discipleship to help
me walk.
And so I floundered along for a
few months and fell headlong into the one and
only long-term relationship.
That I ever entered in after finally coming to Christ.
after finally knowing him it was like getting
your foot caught and a snag.
And just pitching forward into the darkness.
And for three years I lived in that relationship the Lord
drawing me my anxiety getting higher the
Lord drawing me. It was eating me up the
duplicity in my heart. It was eating me up.
until
What was now 33 years
ago on January 27th?
I walked into a service.
And the the person testifying that
night gave an invitation. I wish I
could take your heart into my heart.
I wish I could show you just how good it feels to
let go over the things that you know are killing you.
And cling to the only one who could heal.
And while I didn't recognize myself in his homosexual testimony
didn't recognize or even see that
peace. I knew that I needed that. Peace.
And I came forward.
Waiting for people to pray the junk off of me.
and as I stood there waiting
The knowledge of the holy God came on
me.
And I heard myself pray this prayer. I cannot save myself.
I need you to save me.
And over the next few days strangely.
miraculously my girlfriend broke off the relationship
I didn't see that one coming.
and I began to put together a little obediences first
one little obedience and then another
Titus talks about that too
this is
it says
to the pure all things are pure.
But to those who are defiled and unbelieving nothing
is pure but both their mind and their conscience are defiled.
And then what I read you they profess to know God by
their deeds. They they deny him.
Being detestable and disobedient worthless for
any good deed and I began to agree with God.
It's like first Peter says, you know since then
in obedience to the truth.
You purify your souls for the sincere love
of the brethren.
That is quite A discipleship move
right there.
You say you love?
purify your souls
and the Lord began to put together a history
under my belt when I came to first stone to
serve in 1993. I didn't have any
language except the Bible.
for recovery
I only had Bible language for recovery
and I showed up at first stone and began
to understand that some of the some of
the breakdown.
What what we call the rested development.
There were there were real reasons that anxiety had come
into my life.
And God had real answers for that ways to heal.
You know, he doesn't fix your history. He can't
go back and rewrite the history. But what happens
is he reveals himself and he writes himself into
the history.
He gives you a perspective that comes alongside and begins to
feel that fill the gaps that never could have been
filled outside of that miracle.
so
the Lord did a good work in me keeps
doing it. And I have a phrase that I say a lot. I'm not
as free as I want to be.
In 2004, I married Mark Stanley. He's
pretty cool.
We're very different, but the lord gave me a vow.
To vow at my wedding. I said Mark I will
live with my walls down and my
heart open.
I believe that the lord gave that to me so that over the course of
my life. I would keep bringing those walls
down the defensive walls of hatred
and pain and fear.
And and to be open and the Lord
has used that both in relationship with Mark, but also
in my relationship to the Lord.
Technology issue here. I
don't know how it happened, but it happened.
So is it working now? Okay, there it goes. So there's
Laura Lee's family Laura Lee
was she little girl Laura Lee once Christian
Broadcasting Network Laura Lee
redeemed in Ministry and Laura
Lee meeting. This
guy. He's also really an awesome guy. We
like him and yeah, just
wanted to share that now, I think it's working again.
So yeah, we'll let you share
you. This is Laura Beth Perry. She is an amazing
as Laura Beth Perry small snail.
You're going to find out about that.
So I
I was just so amazed as I sit here and listen to these stories
that I've heard over and over again, but told in a slightly different way
each time and just the power of God in our stories.
And you know, these aren't just stories you read
in a book, but well some of you read the book, but you know,
God has really transformed Our Lives.
And you know, I was one of those kids too. Like Joseph said I
grew up in the church. Every time the door was open we were involved in
every activity. I was in Bible drill and memorized a ton of scripture. I
was in Christian School heard about Jesus all the time, but I
didn't know what I didn't know and I didn't know that I didn't know
the Lord I knew about Jesus I knew about God and
I knew a lot about the Bible, but I did not know him and I didn't know
that I didn't know that and I remember my at
some point. I must have prayed some kind of prayer. I don't
remember it. My parents don't remember it but I
at some point had made some kind of confession of Faith
got baptized. I got baptized because my friend was getting
baptized and really grew up
hearing that I was a Christian and couldn't figure out and my
parents couldn't figure out why I had all these behavior problems.
But I had all kinds of emotional problems. I was
I didn't have a close relationship with my mother for
a variety of reasons. She had her own Brokenness and
struggles. She tells in her
own testimony that the struggles and the anxiety and
the massive health problems. She had and all kinds
of other things trying so hard to live as she put
it in her own words trying so hard to please God in
the power of her own flesh not understanding the power the
Holy Spirit to empower her to live the life that
he had called her to and as a result. She was stressed out. She was
burned out. I was born much later in life and a lot of times she
was just too stressed to handle me. So I was pushed toward
my dad and just told you know, you're just like your dad, you know,
you look like Amy act like him and as
a result, I really begin to detach from my mom
detach from the feminine. I did any I begin to hate my mother at
a very young age. I wanted nothing to do with her and wasn't
close to my sister either for kind
of similar reasons and then if but when
I
A school and I began to hang out with other girls for
the first time. I didn't know how to relate to girls. They
were weird and awkward because I had spent all my
time with my dad and my brother and I really began to believe it
in very early age that I was not like girls.
I knew I was physically a girl but it didn't make any sense
to me. And so I
You know just grew up acting like my brother. I spent
all my time with him that I could I played with this toys. I wore
his clothes and I tried to become my brother
and was so jealous of him growing up and
other boys and I spent all my time playing with boys, and I
was very athletic. So I fit in very well with the boys at school.
But then as I got older and began to realize that
I I was different from the boys as well. I just
didn't know where I fit in.
I was molested by another boy when I was eight. I became
very sexual became very confused hiding a
lot of dark secrets and then when I got into high school was trying
to find love in all the wrong places. I had an extensive
sexual past.
Trying so hard to fix the Brokenness inside and
I didn't know how trying so hard to be loved and accepted and
I hated myself and I couldn't figure out why
I couldn't be a good enough girl what I was no matter what I
gave to men because I kept thinking if I'd give them everything that ever
wanted then they would want me but I was dumped and
rejected and abused and used just over and over and over again.
And I finally looked back on my life
and I was like, you know, the reason this never works out. The reason I'm never happy
is because I was supposed to be the man if I
was a man. I know how to treat a woman and so
I began to fantasize night and day about what this would look like
if I could become a man and I'd still never heard the
word transgender. I mean, this was 2007. I can't believe how
much the cultures changed but I
Began to look this up. And so I I went and
sought out people that felt like I did and I
thought this was the answer to everything. So I was so excited
and I began to just run down that path. I began to
medically transition with hormones. I eventually had my breasts
removed. I eventually had a hysterectomy and had the
ovaries removed and begin to really look like
a man my body began to change my voice began to get lower again
facial hair and all this time. I really started
to believe that I was becoming a man.
But inside of his tormented and haunted because I knew
that I was living a lie, and no matter how much the outside changed. I
was reminded every single day that all of
this was fake that I was making the outside look like
a man but inside I knew that
I was living a lie, and I was reminded of the
truth all the time and I it was
still better in my mind at the time than living as a woman because there
was so much pain I had because of the abuse I'd suffered
from men I felt so
Worthless as a woman I felt like I had no value
as a woman. So I didn't want anything to do
with being a woman but the Lord began to pursue me
and he began to draw me and
I didn't want to be drawn. I had rejected God. I told God I would never serve
him again, but I began to he began to draw me
through my parents' prayers through prayers of people in the church, and I
found myself one day.
Just had a huge revelation of my own sin. And I had seen
the Lord just transform my mom and I I
wanted what she had. I had seen
the real power of God in her life went home
and began to confess everything I could think of and the Lord
encountered me and I had this radical transformation and
I gave my life to the Lord with all my heart and I was going to
be a man of God and I was excited because I
thought this is awesome. I can be a
man of God now and I don't have to go back to that female identity. But
now I can have peace with God and but God
didn't leave me there he gave me an incredible hunger for the word and
as I begin to really pursue the Lord with
all my heart he began to convict me and as he began
to convict Me Slowly little by little over a year and a
half. I couldn't ignore the conviction anymore
and got basically brought
this this first to my heart that
says if anyone will come after me let him deny himself and
take up his cross and follow me for whoever will
His life shall lose it but whoever loses his life
from my sexual find it for what does it profit a man to
gain the whole world and yet forfeit his own soul, or what
shall I give an exchange for his soul?
And I finally agreed with the Lord. I didn't
want to this actually was over the course of several months. I was so
convicted. I beg the Lord to just take my life because I did not
see a way out. I had absolutely no hope of transformation but
I finally decided that I had to obey the
Lord. I thought I'd be miserable the rest of my life. But
as I begin to agree with God over the truth
of how he created me as I began to believe his word
and as I begin to forgive my mom and I forget began to
forgive those that hurt me as God began to bring healing to all
those things as I begin to let go of all the
envy and the jealousy and the bitterness and all those things that have been sewn into
that identity for years. God begin to
bring a radical transformation in me. I begin to really embrace
my feminine and identity. I finally begin to love being
a woman for the first time in my life and then a little
over a year ago. God brought an incredible man into my
life continue to bring some just incredible healing
and we were married last May. This is
my husband Perry.
oh, yeah, so when I was
several months before I left the lifestyle I had
really the
The conviction I was Hunter was incredible because they the
ladies and my mom's Bible say we're praying that I would have a
ravenous hunger for the word in us when I heard that I just laughed
I said, he'll do not know how much God answered that prayer. I was
literally listening to some kind of Christian teaching or
audio Bible hours and hours and hours a day at work and
God was pouring his word into me. And I finally out
the fear of the Lord really hit me and I got down on my
knees and I began to cry out to God with all my heart. I said God I
want everything you have for me. I don't want to miss anything. What
do you want from me?
In the Lord asked me a question. See I was actually expecting God
to say I want you to do this this thing like give me a checklist.
I had to accomplish in my life.
And the Lord's asked me he said if you stood before me tonight, what
name would I call?
And I didn't like that very much because I had heard God calling
me Laura and my prayers and I tried to pretend he wasn't.
As I said, oh God, that's not fair. I I said I Repent
of this I said I was sorry. I know this wasn't your will but I can't
go back now. I have you know, all this facial hair.
I've had all these surgeries. I've had all these legal changes. Everybody here
knows me as a man. I had a job where I was only known as
male I can't go back.
And the Lord reminded me of John chapter 1 where it says Jesus Christ
himself is the Creator and he said you cannot claim to
love me and yet reject my creation.
And I thought I was being condemned because I was not going to go back to being a
woman. It's like Lord. That's just not gonna happen.
And in the most loving voice I've ever heard in all my
life the Lord whispered to me and he said let me tell you who you
are.
And that's really what began to free me not at that moment because it's not like at
that moment. I went. Oh, yes God that is right. It was
that's when I really started asking the Lord to take my life because I
said God that just cannot happen. There is no way out.
But really it began and it was what you've heard in several
of our stories that it really came down to the point where it's like
I want Jesus more than I want my next breath.
And as I've continued to walk with the lord, it's been
one of them, you know, the most difficult things I've ever done but
yet he's been so faithful through it all. I'm so incredibly
grateful to the Lord.
I I just want to finish up with
the testimonies of the Lord
make wise the simple.
I I listen to this all the time and I never
get tired of hearing it. I I hope you've been affected by
the fact.
The culture and the world is telling us one thing
folks.
This is the truth.
It is.
forever
settled in heaven
and this is our goal. This is
the the place that we go.
in all different Church backgrounds
But you know, what's interesting about I think all of us maybe Joseph
Goodman and I but all of us have been
touched by the Southern Baptist Church.
and the standard
is this
and so I just want to say thank you for allowing us
to come and share.
I hope you heard that we're all about this.
And a relationship that is completely surrendered to
Jesus as Lord because then he
saves and delivers and sets us free. We have
all that literature out there and books and
stuff. So want to please Avail yourself
of that and thank you and God
bless you.
Pastor okay, you're dismissed.